passion is the feeling you have that you
would probably do this for free you know
and you can't believe somebody pays you
to do it you know and I think we mistake
that passion is something we do in our
private lives but it shouldn't be done
you know in our careers for example and
I'm a firm believer that you are who you
are and anybody who says I'm different
at home than I am at work and one of
those two places you're lying and the
goal is to make everything you do in
home and it works something that you
have excitement to do so how do you find
the things that you're excited to do
well it's actually easier than you think
what are the things that you love to do
what are the things that you would do
for free you know how can you recreate
that feeling and and be paid for it so
what are the things that I do on the
weekend how do you explain when others
are able to achieve things that seem to
defy all of the assumptions why how what
this little idea explains why some
organizations and some leaders are able
to inspire where others aren't every
single person every single organization
on the planet knows what they do some
know how they do it whether you call it
your differentiating value proposition
or your proprietary process or your USP
but very very few people or
organizations know why they do what they
do and by why I don't mean to make a
profit that's a result it's always a
result by why I mean what's your purpose
what's your cause what's your belief why
does your organization exist why do you
get out of bed in the morning and why
should anyone care the inspired leaders
and the inspire or inspired
organizations regardless of their size
regardless of their industry all think
act and communicate from the inside out
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it the goal is not to do
business with anybody with everybody who
needs what you have the goal is to do
business with people who believe what
you believe
leaders hold a position of power but
those who lead inspire us with other
individuals or organizations we follow
those who lead because we have to but
because we want to we follow those who
lead not further
but for ourselves and it's those who
start with why that have the ability to
inspire those around them
or find others who inspire them you just
watch
- amazing clips from Simon sonic take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]